how's it going hey thank you it's so
good to see everybody Jeremy I'll start
with uh I'll start with you watching
this show at times it feels like a love
letter to old Hollywood and at times it
feels just like an absolute condemnation
to old Hollywood
yes I yes he said it
I think we're challenging this idea of
how you know how things have changed and
how they haven't changed and if anything
we're creating this fantasy world for
you to to to dive in with us we're
asking you to go on this journey with us
and you know the question is what if we
had given these you know people
opportunities women people of color
lgbtq+ members what does that look like
what does that feel like so while it is
a love letter to this glitz and glamor
era that we so rejoice and we we fawn
after it's like what if things were a
little bit different what if we change
the narrative a bit what does that look
like what type of impact does that make
and Jim you know you are the sort of
character that we've all heard these
stories about over the years the the
sort of ugly truth behind how a lot of
this happened for a lot of these stars
but you as a person you were very
lovable people adore you getting into me
Oh was there any sort of hesitation at
all for taking on this kind of guy no no
in fact it was the opposite it was
really there were so many things that
this character does and says the way he
acts and it's despicable as some of it
is and dirty some of it is it's so it
was so different for me that um I was
personally really excited to get to to
put that on for a minute and and see
what kind of as best I could feel my way
through who is this kind of person that
would say these things and do these
things and and because he was a real
person
there was plenty of research about him
and while a lot of the more colorful and
maybe dirty aspects are true there was a
lot of complications to him and a lot of
issues that that that gave them a
balance for me at least in a certain
amount of empathy for him as a gay
that point in time going through trying
to make his way in this business but the
overall effect for me was it was really
a joy it was very playful and Jake you
play Rock Hudson what did you know about
rock going into this and how much work
did you do to sort of figure out who he
was at this point in his life right yeah
I think that's important I mean I was
fascinated just by this era already so
when I first sat down with Ryan I was
cognizant of Rock Hudson who he was I
love that this era I think it's such a
glamorous and triumphant you know story
that we're telling but yeah I pretty
much just did everything I could
anything I can get my hands on any book
washes all of his old films watch them
on silent listen to his interview
studied the body language and just the
relationships he had with his stepfather
and his family so I and I think wouldn't
what you mentioned about you know
touching on that this was like the
growth of Rock Hudson not at the height
of his stardom
I think capturing that essence was what
we tried to really pay homage to and pay
homage to his legacy and it talked to me
quickly about the inspiration behind
being a good actor who is initially a
terrible actor you're a good actor but
you have to like you have to deliver
lines in the way that makes people
cringe what is that like like do you
were like is this back to when you were
younger and just starting out and what
are you what are you tapping into to
play a terrible actor I think just the
willingness to yeah it's difficult but
is that just the willingness to you know
make a fool oneself I think and yeah I
think just Rock going through grappling
with that I think exudes a certain
vulnerability that I fell in love with
personally and made him that much more
fascinating to play these those type of
moments and Jake sorry I'm Jeremy you
know there's so much of this movie is
you know people getting together saying
we can change this world we can change
this whole Hollywood world and we can do
it from the inside that
was happening then and the conversations
are still happening now yeah which is
incredible what still what still needs
to change what what's been fixed what
still needs to change well I think for
me it's this we are the generation as
artists as activists that have to put in
motion the change that we want to see
happen so you know I think very much
like what what Ryan is doing with his
platform of being who he is and having
the resources that he has he's creating
a show that shows you what that looks
like but setting it in the 40s we're
reversing and going let's let's say you
know you know this many years back we
had done what we're trying to do now
we're still trying to give everyone an
equal opportunity whether it's women or
black tea or you the queer community so
again it's it's challenging that
narrative it's showing people what it
looks like what it feels like how
inspiring you can be and hoping that
that would just like lead the charge for
our future and Jim before I wrap this up
how important was this or how paint like
just absolutely crucial was this when
you put on those clothes hmm to sort of
transform into that because your
character has some wild outfits but how
important was wardrobe in all of this
for you
I mean incredibly so both the Wardrobe
and the set it was um it was I have
never worked on a show that has been so
transported as far as taking you really
thrusting you in that area making you
feel that you that you were there I
don't know it sounds a little corny to
say but it's never felt this true to me
as I did on this show was they they they
really went all out with making it
authentic and and the taste level and
creativity with it was just profoundly
good and and you did you you felt it and
you felt like somebody different and you
felt like you were working in a
different time in Hollywood amazing
thank you so much this was incredible
it's it's a different way of doing this
we're all sort of doing it together but
but this was this was great I really
appreciate it thank you so much thank
you very much thanks bro